good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight at some point though it's hard
to imagine now
the current revolution will end
ultimately
all revolutions do end they can't be
sustained
and when ours does we'll wake up one
morning in a country where we don't have
to lie about everything
all the time where math is allowed where
we can acknowledge the profound and
inherent
differences between men and women
without being fired for it that day is
coming
the question is when it does come what
will be left of our society
we can't know the answer in detail but
here's what we're hoping for
we hope that reason remains reason
logic the ability to think clearly and
rationally
that's the one thing we can't lose we're
going to need it to rebuild
that's why of all the moral atrocities
being committed at the moment in the
name of equity and inclusion
it's the relentless attacks on science
that should command our special
attention
so for the next hour we're going to
consider those attacks in some detail
and we're going to start with america's
response to the covet pandemic
when the chronovirus first arrived in
our country last winter most americans
uncritically accepted what the
authorities said about it they thought
they could trust the people in charge
few imagined that our leaders would
leverage a public health emergency for
their own political gain
that seemed like the one line that even
politicians wouldn't cross
and yet almost immediately they crossed
it
around the country democratic governors
used quarantine restrictions to reward
their allies and to punish their
opponents
abortion mills stayed open but the
police kept
churches closed you could buy weed but
you couldn't get your knee replaced
demonstrations against the lockdowns
were banned riots against donald trump
were
encouraged watch the governor of
michigan for example
shamelessly explain the difference
it is probably not going to be safe to
congregate in masses
for quite a while and it's heartbreaking
but we know that michigan is not alone
in this moment that this is what is
happening
all across the country that these big
gatherings just
can't safely happen right now the death
of george floyd has once again shown a
light
on the systematic cycle of injustice in
our country
to the overwhelming majority who have
taken to the streets
and protested peacefully
protesting historic inequities black
michiganders and those across the
country are facing i hear
you i see you i respect you and i
support your efforts
to enact real structural change in
america
so you are no longer allowed to exercise
your constitutional
right of assembly unless it's to
publicly support the democratic party
and it wasn't just the governor of
michigan gavin newsom did the same thing
in california phil murphy did it in new
jersey
it was partisan politics posing as
science
but this was the most amazing part in
the end it was endorsed by
actual scientists and that's the part
that should worry you doctors like
jennifer nozzo at johns hopkins
university
told us that structural racism was a
bigger health threat than the
coronavirus so
go ahead and loot macy's it's an
important part of public health
for those who still believe that
american science was on the level
this was a shocking moment when did the
people who are paid to be rational
become corrupt religious zealots
when did our scientists become
ayatollahs well it happened years ago it
turns out the rest of us just weren't
noticing
in february of 2019 a piece was
published in the journal neurology which
in case you don't read it is one of the
preeminent peer-reviewed publications in
all of medicine
the piece was called lucky and the root
doctor
it described a physician's experience
with a man in the deep south called
reggie
reggie was suffering from a severe
neuromuscular disorder which had left
him blind
modern science might have helped reggie
this was the point of the piece
but he didn't want the help reggie
believed he was blind because he had
been cursed by a voodoo spell that's
what he told his physician
and then he refused treatment and left
the doctor's office for good
now the doctor who wrote this piece
about reggie was a man called william
campbell campbell believed in western
science he did not believe that
voodoo is the cause of blindness and the
peace he wrote was designed to help
other physicians communicate with
patients like reggie
so those patients could receive
effective medical treatment
unfortunately american medical journals
are no longer allowed to criticize
witchcraft
criticizing witchcraft is racist so the
editor of neurology a man called robert
gross began a purge of his own
publication
he fired the humanities editor then he
suspended the entire humanities section
and then to further atone he hired what
he described as a
deputy editor for equity diversity and
inclusion
then robert gross as if this wasn't
enough wrote a groveling apology letter
for the piece
calling campbell's article racist and
acknowledging it had caused quote
anguish
nowhere in that letter did robert gross
explain any of this
why exactly is it racist to prefer
western medicine to witchcraft isn't
that the whole point of our system
gross never explained he just declared
it racist and moved on
so that's now the official policy of
this country's top
neurology journal that witchcraft is the
same as western medicine
and how dare you say otherwise where
does this leave you
if you were nervous about brain surgery
before this is not comforting news
how long before your doctor sacrifices a
chicken in the operating room
that's a serious question we can no
longer say that science
is better than voodoo that's racist
something similar has happened in the
world of economic research
one of the top business journals in the
world the strategic management journal
deleted a paper from the internet
without any explanation
now the key thing to know is all of the
numbers in that paper were
accurate the data were right no one
claimed otherwise
the piece went through peer review it
was published
the piece was published because it was
called this quote
examining investor reactions to
appointments of blacktop
management executives and ceos now
we don't know what those reactions were
it might be interesting to know but you
can't know because the original version
of the piece has disappeared it's gone
it's now in the remote cave where we
hide uncomfortable facts
it's been replaced by a heavily revised
version so what's the truth
we can't know this is the definition
of corruption but it has spread through
science take a look at the
jobs postings at nature magazine nature
was once the foremost science
publication
on the planet what nature is looking for
now in its employees has nothing
whatsoever to do with science in fact
it's anti-science here's one recent job
posting they posted on twitter quote
as part of our commitment to foster
diversity and inclusion
we are looking for a black candidate
with a passion for science communication
based in the uk for a full-time paid
news internship
end quote so the thing that jumps out is
that no whites or asians or hispanics
are allowed
is that legal of course it's not legal
but that's not really the point
the bigger problem and it is bigger than
civil rights law
is that the people we trust to make the
most important decisions
in our society the essential decisions
what kind of medical research do we fund
who gets treatment and who doesn't who
lives and who dies
the people who make those decisions are
no longer rational
they have lost the ability to think
empirically
equity is now their god they no longer
believe
in science that's a real problem hey
sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else